chacun jacques collin
et
oui
bonsoir vous êtes journaliste vous êtes
assis
ex rédacteur en chef du journal voici et
vous publié chez ram c'est un livre qui
s'appelle voilà mille six cent soixante
trois jours dans les coulisses de voix
si vous savez comment on fait jacques
ja quoi vous êtes frais interview vérité
faire un peu d'histoire avant de voir si
effectivement il y avait des journaux
qui s'appelait france dimanche ici paris
et puis voici est arrivé ce qui a fait
la différence c'est peut-être le format
magazine oms qui a fait la différence
c'est que axe élégance et introduit si
je peux dire en france quelque chose qui
n'existait pas jusque là jusque là
c'était une presse qui sont est
faussement la rose c'est à dire que on y
racontait de bonnes choses dans
l'intérêt des artistes et axelrod s'est
dit qu'il fallait faire comme il faisait
en allemagne avec gunter gang ça sonne
bien faisons un journal nazi
il est jalouse qui n'a jamais été dans
l'ouest insurance non mais c'est avec
les gens connus qui sont dans le trou du
cul
[Applaudissements]
riton mois une claque une claque
l'aurait répondre je suis comme tout le
monde j'aurais adoré ne jamais être dans
voici bien évidemment et et un rédacteur
en chef qui connaît même pas les
articles qui paraissent dans son torchon
c'est bien à la hauteur
en est loin avec voici de ce que vous
appelez avec des guillemets ironique
dans votre livre la presse digne de ce
nom où la presse de référence
c'est-à-dire la presse qui fonctionne
soit avec des opérations savamment
orchestrée comme par exemple parler du
vin du come back de isabelle adjani au
moment de la dame aux camélias qui était
considéré par la presse française comme
un succès avant même la première oui en
gros tout est écrit d'avancé terre c'est
un petit peu le problème de la de la
presse qui parle officiellement des
artistes et tout est choisie dit et
écrit d'avancé
et c'est d'ailleurs ce que dit raymond
depardon qu'on ne peut pas soupçonner
d'être un monsieur mal élevés comme moi
il dit il ya quelque chose de fascisant
dans la communication des artistes
aujourd'hui c'est que c'est du border ya
rien qui dépasse et en fait donc ont
finalement on n'apprend rien fait même
plus de la communication c'est la
propagande il ya aussi ce que vous
appelez les traitements de s'avère
certes depardieu quand il est bourré et
qu'il un accident de moto ça fait un
entrefilet dans la presse comme vous
dites de révérence vous dit par exemple
que quand il ya des stars qui sont mis
en cause dans un trafic de cocaïne
les directeurs des infos on les procès
verbaux sur leur bureau et publie aucun
non non non non en france on ne voit
jamais il ya qu aux etats-unis que vous
apprendrez que tel artiste et c'est pas
du tout un choix c'est ce que je trouve
curieux c'est la protection excessif qui
existe sur certaines personnes et qui
n'existe pas sur d'autres parce que
quand joey starr même donner une
pichenette à un singe ça devient une
catastrophe nationale alors au départ
donc voici a été créée par axel ganz
dont vous dites qu'il est rasé lavés
repassés qu'il affectionne les chemises
à poignets mousquetaires les blazers
marine les mocassins gucci le sourcil de
ruggero raimondi le menton de mussolini
est il tout en une seule journée c'est
vrai qu'il a cet accent allemand aussi
aussi prononcer un peu moins prononcée
j'ai un peu caricaturée pour que ce soit
plus plus drôle pour pouvoir faire rire
mon camarade m 6 mai
il parle avec une pointe d'accent
allemands et c'est vrai qu'il m'a blême
mesure gaulin
moralement pas à cola alors le rédacteur
en chef avant vous c'est dominique celle
ura et que vous voyez donc puisque vous
travailler là bas sous ses ordres vous
le voyez vous dites dépérir perdre son
bronzage en 24 heures devenir acariâtre
soupçonneux et surtout obligé d'avoir
des gardes du corps oui parce qu'à
l'époque voici était beaucoup plus dure
qui ne l'est devenu et voici recevez
dominique recevait des menaces alors
donc dominique c'est lui rappelle
beaucoup de sa personne en échange d'un
énorme succès puisque en 95 voix s'y
vend un million d'exemplaires par
semaine en fait c'est la mort de lady di
qui déclenche pendant l'été 98 une vraie
levée de boucliers contre voici haro sur
la presse people vous dites ppda plissa
le front et descendit d'un octave pour
que la chose sonne grave alors votre
mission jacques collin quand vous
rentrez à voici c'est de faire remonter
les ventes aient baissé le ton c'est ce
que vous dites donc pas un boulot pas un
boulot facile à cause de l'opprobe qui
pèse sur vous on le voit encore ce soir
alors vous dites effectivement pour s'en
sortir j'emploie le principe du
collaborateur tout simplement
le principe du collaborateur c'est le
pipe au delà bien cherché et vous dites
d'ailleurs c'est des ingrédients
vichyssois un la cause à défendre de
l'ennemi désigné trois la protection du
pain quotidien oui il ya quelque chose
qui ressemble à ça et que je constate en
parlant avec les gens autour de moi au
fond ils ont pas spécialement envie de
s'attaquer à qui que ce soit mais dans
la mesure où c'est leur travail
quotidien et bien ils sont je dirais un
petit peu comme le monsieur qui fabrique
des mines antipersonnel à roanne c'est
moralité oui parce que tout est morale
et donc ils se cherchent des alibis et
parmi ces talibés ya le fait que
finalement bas les artistes
ça fait pas de mal de temps en temps de
les taquiner à tech inondées mais vous
avez loin quand même parce que vous
allez face à axer le gang jusqu à
fredonner das wunder liste das miller
lite pour montrer votre germanophile il
faut savoir que c'est un ligne de franz
schubert donc c'est pas du tout une
histoire méchant puisque incroyable
c'est que vous le raconte iessa c'est à
vous dites oui effectivement quand on
bosse à voici c'est le principe du
collaborateur on se dit le people l'a
bien cherché quand vous êtes en face dax
landes vous chantez un lead en allemand
pour lui montrer que je vais rien quand
les allemands mais vous le racontez dans
votre livre c'est extra content parce
que c'est ce qui s'est passé c'est
honnête à gré
entre la rue elle disait aucune aucune
autobiographie est intéressante si elle
ne contient pas quelque chose d' abjecte
j'ai je raconte cette histoire parce
qu'elle m'est arrivé parce qu'elle m'est
arrivé d'une façon à la fois volontaire
et involontaire et pour dire les choses
de manière très simple et je l'expliqué
aussi quand j'ai pris ce travail j'ai
pris ce travail parce que j'avais besoin
de travailler et que autant que je sais
juste pas trahi non mais ce travail
n'est pas non si ce travail ne devait
pas exister lorsqu'elle a il devrait
être interdit moi je pense que vous avez
le journal doigté frontière suisse un
baba cool je pense que vous avez allait
alourdir votre karma je pense que vous
avez fait un boulot dans le cul les et
que vous savez très bien en fond de vous
que c'est pas bien alors il ya une
deuxième façon de tenir dans ce job vous
dites dans votre bouquin c'est l'argent
que gagnent les stars en faisant des
procès finalement quelque part ça vous
disculper
noces d'argent ça ne disculpe pas mais
c'est un système qui est propre à la
france parce que c'est n'existe
absolument pas ailleurs en italie les
gens qui sont dans les journaux ne
peuvent pas saisir la justice parce
qu'ils n'obtiendraient rien donc le
système devient pervers dès le moment où
en france il y a des gens qui saisissent
la justice pour des raisons qui sont
honorable et y en a qui saisissent la
justice parce qu'ils ont des dettes de
poker c'est de bonne guerre ça de toute
façon de louer notre photo d'envoi si on
fait un procès on prend ce passage de
l'acceptable entier de toute façon dès
le moment où je fais journal j'en
accepte toutes les données et d'ailleurs
quand je fais ce livre je ne me cache
absolument pas je sais ni un livre où
j'essaye de réclamer le pardon de qui
que ce soit je dis voilà moi j'ai été
plongé dans cette histoire ça aurait pu
être une autre j'aurais très bien pu
être commandos de marines et de voir
assassiné des gens ailleurs finalement
je me suis contenté d'égratigner des
articles ça fait quand même un peu moins
mal je me lance alors vous raconter le
système parce que c'est intéressant de
savoir comment ça marche donc il ya des
informateurs comme partout comme pour
tous les journaux comme j'ai même des
animateurs de télévision qui m'ont
appelé avec je venais un exemple quand
c'était là l'idée est david hallyday ont
divorcé c'est un animateur de télévision
qui m'a prévenu donc ça vaut combien
renseignements
la fourchette que je donne ces 2,2 2000
à 50000 j'ai 55 ans est la plus chère
payée dans les cordes elle y est leur
chance et quoi c'est combien moi ce que
j'ai payé le plus cher de
ce que j'ai payé le plus cher c'est un
ami un prétendu ami de guillaume
depardieu qui est venu m'expliquer quand
où et comment et avec qui ils allaient
se marier à quelle heure etc mais les
renseignements et les soirs comme ça non
c'était vérifié s'est vérifié d'ailleurs
grosso modo on a un taux de réalisation
de 80 % à 85 % quand même d'abord parce
que si ce n'était pas le cas le journal
n'aurait pas eu non plus le succès et
qu'il a ben alors donc vous parler du
système d'information et puis aussi des
coûts a rangé ses dires par exemple vous
vous parlez d'un chanteur de boys band
qui est homo et qu'ils étaient
photographiés en coin planasse mme sarr
dit à venise fait exactement un chanteur
de boys band homos qui est photographié
en compagnie de la compagne du
photographe qui a fait la série comme ça
ça arrive souvent les coups arrangé
comme ça il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
qui en font mais le voici en publie peu
parce que ça marche pas très bien c'est
pas le fond de commerce du vin le frein
de commerce du journal céder réalité
toute simple c'est et ils vont se marier
ils vont séparer ils vont avoir un
enfant pays basque et ouais mais c'est
vraiment que ça hein le reste après ça
n'intéresse plus de façons donc les
coûts arranger il ya différentes façons
d'arranger les coûts par exemple l
animatrice de télévision qui vient avec
un visage tuméfié une minerve suite à un
différend conjugal et finalement vous
décider ensemble qu'on peut pas dire
c'est son mari qui le min remp donc on
va dire que c'est parce que
contrairement à ce qu'essaient de venir
laurent va figer une conscience et on va
voir oui il est conscient et les coûts
sont présentés comme le résultat d'un
braquage en banlieue quoi exactement
savamment la banlieue bah c'est l'idée
qui est née
quels sont les journalistes qui en sort
grandie alors après il ya des trucs
impubliables des trucs que même voici ne
publie pas donc le cadre supérieur d'une
grande chaîne hertzienne urinant sur le
fauteuil d'un présentateur vedette alors
attend la
phrase qu'il a dite à phrase comptez pas
sur moi il ya la chanteuse qui fait une
pipe à son mec alors là ça a été acheté
par un hebdo concurrents plus respecté
que le vôtre ils n'ont pas utilisé la
photo mais la semaine d'après elle la
ramène à un reportage en exclusivité
ouais je ne dis pas qu'il ya un lien
entre les deux
et puis alors que l'attitude de des gens
c'est vrai que vous avez été extrêmement
mépriser cette époque antoine de caunes
par exemple qui vous envoie une lettre
pas très sympa et en revanche chez les
gens avec qui vous devenez ami carla
bruni par exemple est-ce qu'il ya aussi
des gens intelligents carla bruni par
exemple des gens intelligents c'est ceux
qui déjeunent avec vous pour pas vous
parliez de dents dans votre journal et
va je crois qu'au fond c'est ça oui
parce que ceux qui déjeunent avec moi
ont compris que la patère rose on allait
pouvoir s'arranger ouais et bas cela ils
sont quand même un petit peu moins bête
d'une certaine manière parce que
effectivement on s'arrange et c'est eux
qui en profitent le plus parce que moi
je suis marron dans l'histoire souvent
la merde c'est la couleur qui alors
parfois vous vous renoncez en tant que
papa vous aussi vous renoncé à publier
certaines photos c'est le cas avec
christophe dechavanne serre qu'ils vous
le rencontrez et finalement non je vous
avais plus envie de publier les photos
parce que vous dites j'ai une petite
fille lui la plein d'enfants pareil avec
johnny depp johnny depp en fait je même
sans arrêt dans une situation
impossible pour moi parce que si vous
pour faire un journal comme celui là en
fait il faut quelqu'un de beaucoup plus
qu'ils sentent beaucoup plus mauvais que
moi pour le faire reste à trouver c'est
très difficile à trouver puisqu'il s'est
passé dix neuf mois sans que je sois
remplacé donc finalement ce parti a
quand même une espèce malodorantes assez
rare national socialiste est répété être
je ne sais pas mais en tout cas
il est vrai que j'aurais dû me mettre
dijon dans la poupe dans la position
d'un prix pulitzer céder aux
journalistes américains et donne et de
n'avoir aucun contact et refuser tous
les contacts avec les gens parce que
sinon dès que vous rencontrez quelqu'un
et j'ai plus envie de lui faire du bien
évidemment et pied alors il ya l'humour
parce que c'est vrai que j'avais
apportées à voici un certain humour
engagé des gens comme beigbeder comme
patrick besson faisait monter des coups
assez marrant un jour il fait retaper le
livre de claire chazal parent claviste
et en changeant le nom de l'auteur il
envoie le livre de claire chazal à tous
les éditeurs de paris dont le sien plomb
et même plombe refuse le livre de claire
chazal parce que c'était plus signé
claire chazal ça c'est le côté plutôt
marrante voici n'ont cessé les choses
que j'avais envie d'ajouter parce que
pour jeu pour sortir de cet ordinaire
chambre à coucher salle de bain qui
m'amusait pas particulièrement ça
c'était beaucoup plus drôle et en plus
ce qui était intéressant c'est que c'est
les gens quand on leur faisait des coûts
pareil au fond ils vous supplie presque
en continu fait comme d'habitude fait
plutôt de la vie privée parce que fait
pas des choses blessantes comme ça
qu'ils puissent toucher vraiment mon ego
et contre lequel je ne puissent réclamer
aucun argent
voilà qui devrait vous avez été viré
vous aussi finalement parce que je
n'étais pas assez méchant
1663 zour dans l'est
s'il est la même
pour moi si
le
c'est un
vrai scoop sur jacques collin ouais
c'est quoi avant et travailler pour le
captain igloo
la 4éme emirates
les corrections de ne rien rater de
zinal habitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux